für die russen herrscht nicht wie für
die deutschen gleichheit zwischen mann
und frau
hier dominiert der mann die frau sie ist
nur da um ihn zu bedienen darf sich
alles erlauben schließlich ist er ja der
mann legal leute soll ich euch eine
bessere lovestory als bella und edward
von twilight nennen eine bessere
lovestory als bibi und im internet
millionen verdienen eine bessere
lovestory als montana black und auf
irgendwelchen plattformen gebannt werden
die beste love story im internet besser
als alle anderen love stories ist immer
noch der youtube kanal von taff und
beiträge über irgendwelche millionäre
machen wirklich dieser kanal besteht nur
noch aus millionärin aber leute dann und
wann springt auch ein spannender beitrag
raus und so ein habe ich gefunden der
lautet millionärsgattin werden luther
schule zeigt wie man sich einen
millionär angelt es ist also eine schule
in der man lernt wie man eine
golddeckung wird und ich bin sehr
gespannt
[Gelächter]
warum eigentlich immer beiträge über
millionäre es also ich muss nochmal
ansprechen das hobby aber es wirklich
alles alles alles alles sind beiträge
millionäre rechts wie eigentlich ein
millionär hat's vertragen hat die reiche
ehemann geht an millionäre personal
shopperin der millionäre schön und
waldreich beruf millionärsgattin aber
okay wir fahren jetzt auch wie man sich
millionär handelt
schritt eins ein lolli macht einfach
stellt euch mal vor welchem punkt in
seinem leben kommt man an dass man
einfach eine schule für gold digger
aufmacht leute weil einmal die nicht
wissen was der begriff gold digger heißt
fertig und den song von k s an gold
digger sehr wichtig gold digger sind
einfach frauen die so reiche männer
umschwärmen und denen ist dabei
eigentlich nur darum geht was von diesen
reichen wenn dann so ab fällt so an geld
und materiellen sachen für sie und die
ja meistens haben solche frauen nicht so
viel selbstbewusster würde ich sagen
also weil man sich nur für geld so
anbietet so da ist nicht meisten sich
für die liebe im spiel und lernen
die frau sich wohlhabende männer zu am
ende sogar ein okay okay also mit dem
buch ch japan damit mit dem buch die
haare penshorn alle russen ich weiß
gerade könnte auch ihr lernen wie man
sich einen millionär angeln oder ihr
schaut einfach die ersten zehn sekunden
von diesen beitrag und wissen dass man
sich einen millionär handelt indem man
am liebsten lesen sie dieses buch und
der millionär liegt ihnen zu füßen
aber wo sind jetzt auch russlands sind
ein bisschen mehr crazy sogar alle
kennen so diese klischees von den
reichen russen diese abdrehen
vielleicht ist bei den normal bis alle
aber leute ist es wirklich so wenn ihr
dieses buch liest muss im kleinen
sicherheitshinweis an der stelle gehen
das sei darauf vorbereitet ließ dieses
buch nicht nacht weil sie wollte dieses
buch gelesen hat und nach unten schaut
wird da ein millionär liegen an euren
füßen in einem anzug für 10.000 euro
also nicht erschrecken kalkowski es
tipps tatsächlich einschlagen jede bombe
oder eher zu einer flirt flaute führen
wir probieren es auf den straßen der
zwölf-millionen-metropole aus alles da
aber alle menschen die in moskau
rumlaufen sind millionäre oder gehen die
so hin und sagen hey ya vom tv channel
tv sendung taff entfiel auf millionäre
wie office inc gebaut millionäre net
night wenn wir es lieben betrieben auf
millionäre die kurse des russen der
übrigens bereits mit ehefrau nummer vier
zusammen
natürlich hat er selbst schon vier
frauen ist ja klar ist ja ist ja selbst
millionär dass die frage leute weil
versteht ihr weil er wird es dann ja
auch selbst gefahren sagt ja wenn er das
buch herausgibt wie man einen millionär
als selbst einer dann können ja frauen
sein buch gegen ihn verwenden weil das
buch funktioniert ja immer millionäre
sind an ganz anders als andere menschen
funktionieren die leute ihr müsst bei
millionären gibt es einfach so drei
knöpfe die man so drücken muss als frau
und da muss man am logischen und dann
ist man mit dem zusammenhalt ganz viel
geld kriege in russland bereits promi
status
und gern gesehener gast in vielen
talkshows ist doch gleich mal ungefragt
das outfit unserer reporterin auf
millionärs tauglichkeit ganz wichtig
ganz ganz wichtig und auch an oberster
stelle für euch jetzt mal da draußen
leute ich muss mich wirklich
zurückhaltend jetzt hier an dieser
stelle nicht auszurasten so viele leute
wählen ihre outfits in deutschland noch
nach wärme aus danach aus wie optisch
ansprechend sie sind wählen sie auch
einfach danach aus worauf sie gerade
bock haben und ich muss euch sagen was
ihr macht das alle falsch oberstes
kriterium bei der auswahl von klamotten
muss bei jedem menschen auf der welt die
millionärs tauglichkeit sein
also hört auf mit der scheiße jetzt um
eine million her zu hetzen musst du
etwas erotisches anziehen da musst du
dich in linien brett verwandeln die
geschwister hätten es weiter
diese ganze idee war eigentlich immer
spaß und ich habe irgendwie so ein mist
in dieses buch eingeschrieben jetzt
einfach das deutsche fernsehen da was
erzähle ich sie dann jetzt zu tal mit
dem styling sind wir schon mal
durchgefallen
und jetzt analysiert der millionärs
flüsterer auch nach unseren weg bis der
immerhin ein magnet ich sage euch jetzt
wie es ist in meinem kopf sieht die
ganze sache so aus der typ hat irgendwie
kanal in der bank gearbeitet vor zehn
jahren aber so dachte sich entweder
keinen bock hier sitzt den ganztag in
diesem büro müssen wir zu langweilig ich
will nicht mehr so ein bürojob machen
hat sich dann irgendwann scam ausgedacht
um diese leute zu millionären angeblich
werden und verdient jetzt einfach damit
sein geld und kann auch den ganzen tag
lang schöne frauen begaffen läutet
dieser mann hat gewonnen
zarenreich muss lady sich anschmiegen
wie eine katze und alle wünsche dass man
es erfüllen auf uns wirkt das sehr
befremdlich in russland gehöre das aber
quasi zum frau seien dazu so wie kriegst
du das machen wir also das gehört in
russland zum frau seien dazu es gehört
in russland dazu leute sitzen in einem
stuhlkreis
ihr seid eine blonde dame in russland
dann müsst ihr euch falsch rum auf diese
personen draufsetzen aber wirklich auch
also eine art und weise die auch nicht
sinnlich ist oder schön oder so sondern
so als würde
vom stuhl setzen falsch rum so ok das
müssen frauen in russland machen leute
glaubten der server quasi zum frau seien
dazu erklärt uns wie aguilera kowski
kann man kann man sich das militär
begann man sich weniger sexy ob die
shows von einer person setzen
das hilfswerk sie machen einfach so eine
arschbombe darauf das sieht so aus als
hätte sie gerade so psychische probleme
oder sollen braucht so beistand das
sieht nicht so nach verführen aus aber
was weiß ich schon leute schaut mich an
er ist mein outfit millionärs tauglich
nein habe ich folglich irgendeine chance
im leben ein
also ich hatte aber die fresse ich
glaube ich hätte gedacht für die russen
herrscht nicht wie für die deutschen
gleichheit zwischen mann und frau hier
dominiert der mann die frau sie ist nur
da um ihn zu bedienen darf sich alles
erlauben schließlich ist er ja der mann
ok irgendwelche russen da draußen die
das bestätigen kann heute ist es so in
russland das ganze funktioniert
wahrscheinlich einfach so leute also ich
hab keine ahnung von russland mann mann
sitzt in so einem stuhlkreis männer auf
einer seite frauen auf der anderen seite
eine frau läuft rum und setzt sich bei
dem man auch eine chance denn die cool
findet und er sieht ja wohl gemerkt wie
ein kartoffelsack nicht schön und er
steht dann so auf wie er hier und trägt
die frau dann rauscht wie für die
deutschen gleichheit zwischen mann und
frau so und da muss die frau alles
machen was er will so ein linda s warum
sich russen dieses frauenfeindliche
machogehabe leisten können liegt wohl am
chronischen männermangel in russland
gibt es rund zehn millionen mehr frauen
als männer
das ist aber echt ein ding das ist krass
leute das ist wirklich krass wird der
grund dafür ist geistern guck mal hier
die einen artikel an
da geht es wirklich ein traum saufen so
russlands männer saufen einfach zu viel
wodka sei das klingt wie sodass der
dümmste das dümmste was man sich
ausdenken kann aber scheinbar ist es so
zehn millionen mehr frauen als männer
wo zahlreiche studien liegt das unter
anderem daran dass sich die kerle sehr
früh ins grab saufen 25 prozent werden
nicht mal 55 jahre alt liga 25 prozent
sterben vor ihrem 55
geburtstag bruder dass er geisteskrank
das geht überhaupt nicht legenden
besagen dass laura müller diese schule
besucht hat ich sollte einen tausch in
der geschlechterrolle gegeben die frauen
haben von den männern übernommen dass
sie stark sein müssen nun selbst geld
verdienen die männer von den frauen und
dass sie ein kleines mädchen sein können
ok also also doch wie deutschland ok
alles klar wir jungs unter meinen zu
schauen wir haben jetzt natürlich zwei
optionen ja wir können jetzt wählen
option eins wir sind wie die russen ja
wir sind nicht kleinen mädchen sondern
sind richtige männer und saufen uns
gefälligst zu 25 prozent ins grab vor 55
ok oder wir sind halt wie in deutschland
verweichlicht und leben so bis 80 oder
so was natürlich ganz lächerlich ist
schon schlimm doch auf welchen typ frau
stehen die superreichen millionäre
bevorzugen schöne elegante frauen die
aber auch klug intelligenz und beruflich
erfolgreich zugleich sind okay stimmt da
gebe ich dem komplett recht also ich
kenne ein paar auch in meinem
persönlichen umfeld und die
allerwenigsten oder ich glaube sogar gar
keiner den ich jetzt persönlich kenne
also mit kennen manche millionäre die
ich kenne stehen auf so asi um gebildete
frauen die einfach nur gut aussehen und
sonst nichts können doch die erfolgreich
ist das geheimrezept rakovsky wie es in
seinem buch steht kleine yusen um den
ersten kontakt herzustellen
bitte sorry ich muss jetzt an der stelle
moment unterbrechen kann man bitte
einfach dieses wort normal aussprechen
wer weiß eines tages in seinem leben auf
und denkt sich ja heute spreche ich das
wort lutschen lutschen ok kurze solution
aus sowie suchen
ich habe vor man würde suchen suchen
aussprechen ja klingt doof naja so genau
so klingt auch lutschen also leute was
nehmen wir aus diesem video beitrag mit
zwei dinge für die frauenrolle lutschen
für den man einfach eine frau nehmen und
aus dem raum wegtragen
wenn ihr diese sache näher erläutern
kann zu einem 102 pleite unter den
kommentaren checkt hier ein
vorgeschlagen das video ab bonität main
kanals bin an der stelle raus hat das
hat mir sehr viel spaß gemacht
haut rein das gut ich küsse raum